viene a tutti ragazzi e poi venuto
questo video sono fa vigenti
oggi siamo su the game si chiama di game
praticamente ragazzi vi ricordate sto
gioco per caso deve adesso devo sparare
arcobaleni dal culo fantastico mi
mancava sta cosa ragazzi hanno fatto il
seguito hanno dei problemi comunque a si
iniziano prima che
una gara che cosa sta in con santo
freddo che cosa cazzo sta succedendo lì
per cos'è ace 1 col joystick
certo
i ragazzi hanno ancora capito non ho
ancora capito se siamo per chi è
successo a era un cazzo di già bello era
un gioco fantastico violento molto
violento mi sta piacendo bellissimi
ragazzi proprio giocare per vederla
anarchia daddy games ha certo le regole
del gioco nessuna regola gioca e basta
perfetto va bene e io posso mi muovo già
per ragazzi sono contentissimo di
tornare su sto gioco perché veramente mi
dà soddisfazioni vabbè io ragazzi ancora
non si sa è che questo dovrebbe strain
stein bellis già giocavamo sto gioco
ragazzi ti va bene che ama non possiamo
andare io io ho una vita al di fuori di
questo adesso
sono andato a sinistra niente sono morto
il punto è che non c'è un punto ma è
ovvio no seriamente un livello per
riempire ritorno indietro mi stai
prendendo per non c'è porno se sono stai
chiedendo me lo sto chiedendo si vabbè
ma comunismo the game
la serie ma io vi giuro ma perché i
comunismo 2 la vendetta
bellissima la medaglia livello 1337 bene
ok questo mi piace mi piaceva prossimo
livello censura the game
censura a è tutto così c'è un cazzo
bello giorno sono mai sentito parlare
delle olimpiadi di sparando in faccia ad
game questa dovrebbe essere ok
queste spara alle anatre non è una
un uomo d'affari con mi fai capire se
devo sparare degli uomini da fare a chi
ho appena sparato legali preciso chi
giuro cioè non voler così ma questo è
walter white è la madonna cc ne va beh
mi sta inventando sto gioco domestics
find the game
raga io ho paura che basta a volte ma
cosa serve piegarsi per prenderlo nel
deretano che tanto ci sono da suicidarsi
sto gioco scherzi anni mi buttò dsulla
registrato 7 si deve far saltare in aria
st persona per favore ditemi che non è
così
è il mio a morte all'america certo
alcolismo the game ceca lag click al
bastardo ubriaco per partire questo sono
morto ho resistito zero secondi a specie
fermi che non ho capito la voglia di
fare questo clicca il bastardo si doterà
premuto perfetto devo camminare sulle
stesse ma perché fermi ragazzi che non
sono ubriaco non sono non è quello che
pensate cosa c'è scritto sono morto va
bene ok forse un pochettino bevuto ma
giusto un po a rega non bere e non
guidare non bere non guidare non bere
non mi dà ok io ho ragazzi sto avendo
paura
i cinque stage di che cosa mi
rappresentò suicidarmi ovviamente io non
so che
ma perché l'hai fatto è che posso fare
solo quello zio mac e c 89 scelta da
fare che per favore non uccidermi tieni
premuto spazio io danzerò per te
seriamente a hai visto posso fare il tip
tap
ma perché se posso fare a prendendo ba
bellissimo e stato bello
beh perfette cos'è questo è il depresso
si è ucciso da solo beh che bello e
divertente a questo è quello che accetta
le cose così come sono perfetti e stato
magnifico i tuoi problemi sono finiti
sfortunatamente sei finito anche tu eh
vabbè prossimo livello astinenza da
james regole del gioco non fare niente
ok
sia vera gara che posso sta qua tutto il
giorno
clicco lo stesso hamas è mosso
e allora non succede un cazzo prendi per
il culo se ucciso o merda cosa è
successo il tuo computer a contratto
l'esse ti di server transmitter data si
grazie mi e piu trojan virus al westin
norton antichissima comiche pubblicità è
questa next level thibert del game certo
dipende dalle tinte mista pia per culo
cioè marocco so cliccato tibet e le
sloggiato dalla cina grande femminismo
the game
vanni a prendere un panino questo già
scritto non capito a ma sono tipo adamo
ed eva fantastico
[Musica]
global warning di game che ami chiari su
rischio surriscaldamento globale di game
perfetto questo anche vincendo che a
perdere sono noi ragazzi si pensi giochi
platform impossibili sono legato mi sta
prendendo l'adrenalina a mille cazzo
altro che gta 5 set point past the poi
intorno riabbassa al punto di non
ritorno
morto perché dovrebbe esserci un gioco
sul surriscaldamento globale io devo
capirlo ma forza piccola [ __ ] sì ce
l'ha fatta
non so come cadono sti cosi non cade un
casi sta accadendo invece porca [ __ ]
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye dall'inizio
bp per il culo e ragazzi come ho fatto a
morire prima che non ho capito violento
la famiglia giuro ragazzi somma ragazzo
morto 400 volte non ho neanche capito
dove però a ok perfetto dovrei averlo
schiva non lo so ragazzi prossimo io
mica fai vivere in uno si seppe so mi
cadesse addosso l'ultimo mandata di culo
ve la do ragazzi se muoio mi cazzo ci ho
messo delle ore cose gorgo di qua gore
mansion
non so dove sto andando poi politici
sono in un altro castello mcleish laird
game che sei becker nonché figure una
sana che ci sono tutti il top non ce n'è
uno di preciso e tipo un gioco ottico
che cazzo è successo caduto bene
benissimo riarmi affetto meglio di così
no ok io sono un fenomeno attira
affacciata ormai ragazzi scienza dei gay
getting down with galileo
ma veramente quindi devo doppio suicidio
facile a 10 c'è anche il punteggio bello
grazie per jami franklin e la madonna
che figo è morto era e che storia
tragica anime djane mio piano che so
voglio vedere cocus sei tu
66 allora si va la smettiamo anni fa ste
cagate no non può essere una bellissima
next level artisti musicali di game 2007
vm i presidi spears io vado su questo
ragazzo serio by brick forza cazzo
succede l eutanasia the game
[Musica]
ma come ma veramente o clicco
continuiamo così tutto il giorno ma
venetico cerotto è sono morto
alternativa medicina alternativa the
gift tamagotchi ma cosa io andrei
sull'esorcismo assolutamente sì
non ho capito un cazzo gesù pacifismo
the game ascolta cosa c è di farci fini
sta dentro livello ma non c'è la sorella
sprone a kimi non è nei momenti
divani the game va bene ha detto
commissioni imposti col sì ma senso di
questa cosa sta succedendo ma devo
scassare divano cazzo prima che lo
scassi lui perché aveva un macello ma
rileva bervi lager 8 valido è la madonna
non ha senso roll the games no ti prego
almeno questo non crei mi spazio per
sparare commenti brutti
lol non ho capito ma ok per mara i
commenti devo ammazzare la gente di
sopra io vado avanti a uccidere persone
a caso comunque il cane è bellissimo ci
ha fatto dire ascoltate non è finito il
tempo e [ __ ] che è successo
bannato grazie anche al trofeo bradley
richiamare il tuo premio serio già fatta
subito ma [ __ ] hanno rifatto
stiamo cercando di capire se era è
veramente così
ma reputo benissimo è uguale ragazzi non
è bellissimo ma serio tua rickroll no ma
veramente ci ho provato ragazzi
supernatural claims ma vi prego possiamo
finire cosa cioè sei serio o mio dio
cos'è che cosa orribile
io non dormo più lo dico non sto più
dormendo definire calmi tutti è bello
happy halloween anche a te amico you
drop dei rave non aspettatevi che fermi
un attimo che non si può ben essere
ah ok perfetto era già sei incensurata
di sud va bene v and the game ragazzi
alla fine la fine secondo me io ho il
presentimento per chiamarci il
presentimento io mi debba suicidare però
non ne sono sicuro ci però è io lo
sapevo io lo sapevo se ragazzi non ci
potevo più fare stavo il mio cervello
sta per esplodere ve lo dico e stato
veramente ma veramente strano ma strana
di importo voglio fare un applauso a
questo creato ai creatori di questo anno
si è schiantato ci mancava lo schianto
finale non c'entra se vinci o perdi
c'entra come tu giochi il gioco the game
madonna che frase filosofica finale
della madonna comunque ragazzi concluso
che l'episodio è stato veramente strano
ma veramente vero che comunque vi sia
piaciuto c'è bisogno di tranquillità
mentale quindi ragazzi se il video è
piaciuto consente lasciando commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook può
avere questo anche nel menu 9 min attimo
ma che cazzo ma cosa ma vabbè la finisco
anche a pagina di facebook che condivido
trattare descrizione colore siti simili
ci vediamo al prossimo video e ragazzi